whoop which is [ __ ] fantastic
and i don't think they're sponsors i got
rid of my apple watch because of the
whoop they're they're they are the best
uh wearable
tracks fitness tracking device known to
man i wish i had my thing i would love
to go through my numbers with you i'm
sure it's in the [ __ ] man cave yeah
whatever
but like i want to know my i want to
know my hrv now i'll text it to you when
i get i'll text you i text rogan my
recoveries every morning i go [ __ ]
tequila
i mean what are rogan's recovery he's
like 100
so so the i mean i don't i'm i hope i'm
not speaking at school but the only
reason anyone knows about whoop is
because of us yeah because we did sober
october
and so
so we got we were the first generation
of dudes getting whoops so when we got
whoops we were like
it was like first of all we didn't
understand any of it
but
joe rogan put a [ __ ] dent in it he
his whoop at the end of every day must
be like
i mean
his [ __ ] like
you'd get you'd get his uh his his
activity you know you start activity and
you can track it yeah and it was just it
looked like the [ __ ] swiss alps
and he would burn he would keep his
heart rate 10 am he would keep his heart
rate in the red like at like 171 for an
hour straight and you and i'd be like
what the [ __ ] he would work out so
[ __ ] hard and then his recovery
like
a hundred percent green like he would
just go like
he he's a different animal he would work
out like a beast and then when he
decided to go to bed he would sleep for
eight hours exactly and wake up like
i never got to eight hours i was always
at like seven hours and fifteen minutes
i i i get grumpy if i'm less than eight
hours oh i can't i slept great last
night i slept nine hours last night and
uh
[ __ ] slept awesome panic attacks in
the morning but whatever that's normal
dude speaking of rogan can i officially
thank you in person for the kind words
you said about me and my podcast and my
comedy i don't even remember it it was
yeah you had a tony hinchcliffe on last
time you're on rogan it's like the first
10 seconds well yeah
because rogan said he said i want to do
a podcast in a sprinter van he says i
want to make a podcast studio in a
sprinter van you said yeah stevo does
that yeah yeah well i mean my my
feelings about you were genuine so i
don't i don't i mean that's how i feel
about you i i
i try and i mean there's a few people
i'm
impressed by you know like where i go
oh god they're doing it good you know
and it's for a number of different
things
um
but are you you consistently impressed
me
and it's like i said i didn't say this
on the thing and there but like it was
really cool was cbs we both did pieces
of cbs
cbs came over to my house and they were
like yeah there's like this great and
they're like do you own all these
cameras like you know i can i tell you
i'm really
uh jamie was saying this because i'm
really impressed by stevo i was like
yeah he's like he's like a like a
businessman like he knows what the [ __ ]
he's doing and i was like oh yeah i was
like oh i could spend my whole interview
talking about steve if you want i
[ __ ] love the guy
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude